hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday august 10th
um
was that the naked gun steer right two
two two what's going on how are you how
was your day going how was your weekend
did you have a good time and everything
well that's awesome
i am on vacation
vacationing um i've been doing [ __ ] for
the last three four days i caught a
little bit of the uh the cowboys game
against uh
who did they play there they played the
uh the so-and-so's i saw the end of the
chiefs broncos
and the cowboys played the eagles
that's right
gave them a good old-fashioned beatdown
for the unprecedented
17th game
you know
of the season can you imagine the
records that are going to fall
they get an extra game every year
i imagine at some point if they get done
throwing the [ __ ] ball in every down
i would think eric dickerson rushing
yards in a season
you know are they going to bring out the
asterisk the roger maris asterick well
he only did it in 68 games
you know o.j simpson
say what you want about his personal
life the man rushed for
2003 or 4 yards
in a 14
game season
it's almost as if when the man puts his
mind to something
nothing can stop
him sorry
um
anyway um i have no idea what's going on
i am out in the middle of nowhere
i could turn on the tv and i guess i
could watch some sports but i'm kind of
enjoying myself just shutting it down
just taking stock
um
yeah i just been chilling out out here
in the wilderness with my lovely wife
for the last couple of days and by the
time you hear this we will be back
to the nut house that is la but i'll be
honest with you you know
i'll be honest with you a day and a half
i'm you know
i'm ready to get back
i'm a lunatic i don't know what it is
because then i feel like after like
two three days this is a three day or
right after three days then i never want
to go back
day and a half i'm like all right i feel
good i feel relaxed i i can still go
back and do this
this [ __ ] right and then after like
three days i'm just like what does it
all mean i mean
time's going by and just the [ __ ]
gonna write another hour of [ __ ] jokes
for the people um bill you don't write
for the people you're right for yourself
you're selfish bald [ __ ] there we go
sorry see you didn't even need to do it
by the way
um i don't know how i missed this
probably because i never watched the
news or anything i didn't realize the
great mike nezmuth
from the monkeys
passed away in december and i was
working i was going to go see them at
the greek theater
when then the two surviving members
mickey dolans and mike nezmuth were
playing
and um
i was so sad to hear that news i really
was but really also admired the way that
man seemed to live his life where he
really did what he wanted to do
he created what he wanted to create
and um
he just operated at a really high level
and then not to mention
um
the monkey show itself was such a huge
thing for me when i was a kid because it
combined two things i loved the most
comedy and music
and um
i don't know that's that was a that's a
tough one man
i love those guys to know that there's
only one guy left
holy mackerel
that's why you gotta live your life man
uh
but anyway
um
yeah
rest in peace mike nezmuth and uh
peter tork died a couple years ago i
want to say in like 2019
2018 2019 and davey jones passed away
a long time ago i feel like in the 2000s
or something
um
unreal
i remember making this joke when i was
in liverpool even though i was sad about
the death i still had to make a joke i
did a gig in liverpool and peter tork
had just died
and liverpool's the home of the beatles
and i was just like all right
two beetles are dead two monkeys are
dead who's gonna win right
[Music]
they gotta laugh but now i'm thinking
the beatles were up
two
dead members to none
and the monkeys have come roaring back
to make it three to two
will the beatles get the equalizer what
am i doing sorry um
anyway
what else are you gonna do just dwell on
the sadness of it speaking of dying and
age i saw one of the dumbest [ __ ] i
can't say the dumbest [ __ ] things but
like a typical stupid thing that was
trending on the internet it was about
some supermodel who was in her 50s
and they were going she had the audacity
to age
like that's like a new like
liberal [ __ ] they love the word
audacity
she had the audacity to have a thought
you know
he was a man and had the audacity to
want to be a woman like they love
throwing that [ __ ] word around
so
it's this whole article about a
supermodel who evidently is in her 50s
and i think her husband died or
something so now she's going out into
the clubs and she never got botox
and she's bitching that in her 50s
nobody's looking at her
it's like yeah you're in your 50s
no one younger wants to [ __ ] that i'm
sorry
and she was acting as though it was some
sort of unique experience
like somehow a man in his 50 50s can
walk into a club and start banging like
young chicks are like oh my god
they're not you're 50 you're gross get
out
unless you own the place get out of here
stop being a creep going out to the club
yet let young people have their [ __ ]
time
i know there's women what are you
talking about
she's a predator
she's a [ __ ] predator she's gonna
take all his money that's why she's
there she is choosing
money and stability over love there's
three types of people out there in the
dating scene there's people who are
actually looking for love
there's people that marry for looks
and there's people that marry for money
slash stability
and those people that marry for looks
and they marry for money
usually get spit out the other end one
on on some side of a divorce in their
50s and then they go out there
and they wonder why nobody gives a [ __ ]
anymore it's it's cuz you're old
people my age still trying to be like
sexy is just it's [ __ ] how don't you
remember what it was like as a younger
person
to see somebody coming in with their
lizardy skin
you know
or how creeped out the women were when
some older cologne stinking guy came
walking in it was just the dumbest thing
ever and plus also i just feel like you
know
that's just like a classic [ __ ]
you know female thing where when it
works for you it's all good and then
when it doesn't you need to change it
it's just like you were a supermodel how
many cover charges have you paid in your
life how many drinks did you actually
[ __ ] have to buy
when you were young and gorgeous so now
you're [ __ ] old and now all of a
sudden you want the saloon doors ain't
swinging the way they used to be you
know we're all supposed to [ __ ] feel
bad
don't know sorry i hate to tell it
you're in your 50s so your options are
to get with someone who looks like me
an old
bald orange man
that's your wheelhouse
you know what i mean
well you could try to find love she was
like upset that she like evidently that
she was walking into the club and guys
in their 30s didn't give a [ __ ] yeah
they don't
they don't the same way when you were in
your 30s you didn't want some [ __ ]
bald orange guy in his 50s being like
hey baby what's your sign
oh god get away from me i'm [ __ ]
young and bitter right and then all of a
sudden
you know
she starts getting up in there you know
into the old [ __ ] nothing too she still
looks great that's what's funny she
still looks [ __ ] great so i don't
know like
i'm supposed to somehow uh make a
supermodel feel good about her looks
oh i'm sorry i'm sorry you weren't
one of the most beautiful women on the
planet for your entire life god that
that must be so difficult
so of course that sends me down this uh
this [ __ ] rabbit hole which is the
usual thing women acting women like that
acting as though only bad things happen
to women and that guy's ah [ __ ] guy
could be 117 years old hey he's got 22
her girlfriend that no that's not what
happens if he has a billion dollars he
does and she's [ __ ]
she's putting [ __ ] uh i don't know
salmonella and his goddamn eggs or
whatever can you do that can you buy
salmonella
sorry i was trying to think of a poison
and i panicked
i couldn't think of anything um arsenic
there we go rat poison
putting rat poison in your colostomy bag
um
so there was another one where there was
this woman going like
you know uh
back when i was a model i got fired for
being a size four which i guess is small
i haven't cross-dressed in a while i'm a
little a little rusty on my
women's sizes numbers so she was a they
fired her for being a four
right
said she was too fat so she goes joke's
on you i'm now at ten
you know and i can pick up your odd dad
cause i had the audacity to be a four
that's what she said then she goes jokes
on you i can now
lift up your audacity
and and i forget what because now she's
like a weightlifter or something like
that
so it's like all right well
that's a good thing then like what what
is
there's no audacity
in modeling it is what it is when you go
into it
you're not eating
everybody knows this like what they're
bitching about that would be like a
quarterback going like you know
i just got replaced at quarterback
because i had the audacity to be 35
years old in the nfl and they decided to
draft a younger guy with the stronger
arm
because i had the audacity to age it's
the same [ __ ] thing
three years ago i got kicked off my
football team because i had the audacity
to blow out my acl
to get a knee injury playing football
it's like yeah that that's what happens
that's what happens all right
everybody
has their moment in life and when your
moment is over
or if you can't live up to what the the
the the level of excellence is
then you got to pick something else
you know
the [ __ ] are you complaining about
you got to be a model that's amazing
amazing it's amazing right
then you got to be too big for them
which who gives a [ __ ] what they think
and now you're lifting weights that's
[ __ ] great
[Laughter]
[Music]
that the audacity
i get i got a feeling that word's going
to be around for a while
use like that
you know
i had the audacity
[ __ ] audacity can you [ __ ] believe
it it's like yeah that's that's how it
works it's like if you're an athlete you
gotta understand that like
any day somebody comes in and does your
job better you're out you're done
if you're a coach
you lose a couple games in a row your
ass is on the hot seat you got to sell
your house and pull your kids out of the
school they just made friends at it's
just it's how it works
i've never seen like a football coach
like
i got fired because i had the audacity
to only be nine and seven three years in
a row you couldn't get us over the hump
you're out
[ __ ] you and your dream
you know
granted football coaches can be fat
[ __ ]
but it's not a beauty contest
i don't know
i just understand why that [ __ ] thing
starts trending
kind of glad it did because it gave me
something to talk about here because
i've been doing [ __ ] the entire time oh
i got something else here hope billy uh
on the internet watching the news here
i'm doing all topical material have you
seen that new [ __ ] apple watch
commercial where it's 9-1-1 calls people
made on their apple watch
like how few [ __ ] apple watchers are
they selling because most people like me
like oh i got the [ __ ] phone i don't
even it's a clock on the phone
you know what i mean
so then they have all these people
calling and these just these [ __ ]
horrifying scenes this woman drove a car
in a lake course
crazy broad no i'm kidding um
[Music]
that's why they shouldn't be driving you
know you don't hear a guy talking in his
apple watch and he [ __ ] drove his car
into a lake i'm just saying
i had to use my apple watch to call the
police because i had the audacity to
drive my car to a lake
i feel like if i was a man driver they
wouldn't put that lake there
hello double standard nature
um
anyway so this these [ __ ] people are
like one woman is drove her car into a
lake and as far as i can understand is
in an air pocket
talking to the cops
another guy's like i'm in a bar and i
broke my leg i can't get up
oh you got to come get me come get me
it's going to get bad quick
oh come get me right
and in the middle of all that
for some reason
he says
i couldn't reach my phone so i called on
my apple watch
right
like who gives a [ __ ] product
endorsement in the middle of a [ __ ]
9-1-1 call i'm calling [ __ ]
on that commercial i'm not saying the
guy didn't use his apple watch i'm not
saying he didn't break his leg in that
barn
all right
what i'm saying is i think afterwards
they did a little uh little you know
they added the embellished these are
actual
911 calls and then they added
can you just say that you were calling
from your apple watch
like how does that
he didn't even say i'm calling from a
watch which you probably try to use as
few words as possible if you were laying
in a barn with your leg buster but this
guy's like i'm calling for my apple
watch i got the turquoise one my wife
loves it so does her sister i think i
might get a threesome you should buy one
oh yeah my address is
i don't know i'm calling 100 [ __ ] on
that
nia would you agree
on the uh there's a new apple watch
commercial yeah it's really unsettling
oh am i back on the podcast yes come
here
so um
what they want that's right
a happier some more sunshiny vibe
so this is apple what are you
complaining about now
um the apple watch commercial
all complaints all the time all
complaints all the time that's right
yeah oh you told me about that i haven't
seen this commercial but you told me
well it's this 9-1-1 commercial and this
woman's like god draw my card to a leg
what is up to my neck and there's this
other guy he's going like i'm busting my
leg i'm in the barn he's trying to
[ __ ] yakking it bit back a yak
whatever trying to [ __ ] a pig and
his friends came over oh goodness and
then there was somebody else i don't
know where the deal is like i'm trying
to put this dress on i can't zip it up
right
so the guy's laying in the barn
after whatever he tried to [ __ ] kick
them in his legs
don't don't mate don't make it seem like
people who work on a farm sleep with the
farm animals that's not nice
what do you mean
that happens all the time
how would you know did you grow up on a
farm oh my god you are so tone deaf am i
tone deaf or naive what do you mean like
why do you think they have
farmersonly.com
[Laughter]
why can't because farmers and the cows
can hook yeah so nobody knows what
they're doing
no
so anyways this guy's laying in the barn
ah my leg's all busted up and he goes i
couldn't reach my phone i'm calling from
my apple watch you would never tell a
9-1-1 dispatcher that they would be like
we know
we can see everything on our monitors no
but why would you do a product
endorsement yeah that exactly i just sat
down and had a pepsi and i slipped in my
uggs and i failed and bust my leg
calling you on my apple watch but so
yeah so the point is that you can call
9-1-1 from your apple watch i bet your
regular [ __ ] timex won't do that huh
i know but you could also call them from
your [ __ ] guest watch
your swatch watch no this is this is
what they're doing they've realized
that they they
put a hat on a hat when they made the
[ __ ] apple watch because you already
have a clock on your phone and you can
already make phone calls on your phone
yeah
so they [ __ ] they're like what do we
do here
they have to create this fear that
you're going to drive a car into a lake
and your phone's going to be like i
don't know underwater yeah but you can
still call 9-1-1 yeah
well how come her watch wasn't
underwater she went in like she was on a
roller coaster like
putting her arms up yeah baby thelma
louise yeah is the watch like waterproof
up to eight feet or something because
that's also something that they should
consider if it hasn't already been done
which i'm sure it has
it was all just really convenient i
think that somebody who runs apple over
there demanded that one of their new
employees who wanted a better office
show loyalty to the company
and drive her car
or prius
into a lake
and then they recorded the whole thing
it's like but you just can't
say that we had this conversation and if
you do that
we will let you sit in steve's job's
office which has remained locked since
he's died
you can sit in there for 20 minutes and
she said yes
and maybe you'll be a fraction
of as brilliant
as our great leader was
yeah you can you can put on his
turtleneck one of his turtleneck
sweaters
i'm just saying i'm calling [ __ ]
okay yeah i mean that's that's
definitely seems a little far-fetched
i had to call 9-1-1 because i had the
audacity to drive into a lake i suppose
it's that extra layer of security that
you had your phone you have your watch
you have many things on you where you
could call for help if you're ever in
peril
so and all of them are tracking you and
then people don't want people don't want
to get microchipped i still don't
understand like apple tags have you seen
these are you going to get microchip
neal why would i get microchips exactly
but have you seen these um what sort of
fight are you going to put up we talking
red dawn here
i feel like i would put up a pretty good
fight if someone tried to head knock it
up
[Laughter]
yeah
stop dirt bag what was that what would
she say don't move dirt bag
in police academy yeah private hooks i'm
pretty i'm pretty scrappy and you know i
fight dirty too so i'm kind of like
i'm going for every possible orifice i'm
you know scratching whatever i can
scratch
you know at the very least i'm getting
some evidence underneath my nails so
i know but you'll be attacking the
government so you'll go to jail what do
you mean they said it's i've read this
[ __ ] article and this [ __ ] nerd is
going like yeah it's inevitable so you
can't even fight it oh that they're
gonna actually force people to be
microchipped where are people getting
this idea that that's actually going to
happen because there's some idiots that
work for companies that have already
done it this is what they can do they're
going to scare you about your kid just
like the apple watch commercial like i
drove my kids into a lake i can't find
them they had some lady on i have to
look it up it was years ago that they
had some lady on some morning show and
she had voluntarily gotten her and her
entire family microchipped for like
tracking safety reasons it's already
been done but it's not like they're
forcing you to it's not like you know
they're lining you up that's how it you
know initially you know they came out
with the vaccine and you didn't have to
get it choice
and now and now in australia i believe
they're beating people aren't they
australia is not [ __ ] around not
[ __ ] around they told [ __ ] around
and if you screw it up that's why what
they're mad at that tennis player right
is that what you were telling me they
weren't mad at the tennis player the
tennis player was coming in to make them
some money and then they looked the
other way and then they all these
australians were like crikey yeah
wait wait
that's not nice yeah you're right you
can't make everybody else do and then
this person gets an example exactly
that's not okay yeah they're [ __ ]
lunatics they're gonna come up my head
butt that guy right in his teeth they
don't want your [ __ ] virus they don't
want your dogs they don't want your
strange plants or fruits that's new
zealand don't i thought australia was
like that too
i don't know you can't bring any
different kind of eco
i think that was new zealand australia
didn't give a [ __ ] bring you any kind of
like living thing or whatever into their
ecosystem because you might throw the
whole [ __ ] off balance
no australia doesn't care you can come
in do whatever you want and then take a
[ __ ] on the great barrier reef they
don't care
they're all about the money in australia
oh i'm sure
i might have that wrong it's been a
while since i've been there i think you
have it ron
i think they are
very determined to keep their beautiful
landscape and it is beautiful the most
beautiful beaches i've ever seen in my
life zealand was like magical no it's
just though it's you know i'm talking
australia
australia is amazing too i was just
saying i liked the
the waterfalls and the beaches in new
zealand i thought they were magical
new zealand had like the toughest people
i've ever seen in my life the the native
new zealanders all look like hall of
fame linebackers or defensive tackles
every single one of them was like but
not [ __ ] with that guy would not [ __ ]
with that guy remember when we flew in
the airport and everything was like
harry potter
it was all the dragons and all that
stuff in the airport do you remember
this yeah because they shot that down
there yeah and you know why the safety
video was like the cast of lord of the
rings that's right yeah not harry potter
lord of the rings
the cast in the safety video they had
like [ __ ] elijah wood i feel like it
was directed by peter jackson like they
just went all in
well because they shot it down there and
they don't recognize sag down there so
they only had to pay the actors once it
was a big uh it was a big fiasco
was it
oh yeah like the director of that movie
never got paid they they was sick they
made like six billion dollars on paper
was still not in profit and he had to
sue them
i think he had to keep making lord of
the rings just so they still needed him
so he'd get paid it was one of the worst
things ever and then as he was suing
them i believe they got bought by
another corporation so he was chasing a
ghost and it was all legal
really
this all happened yeah look it up okay
damn
if he only had an apple watch he could
have called his lawyer and he would have
been fined
even from the middle of the earth you
could have called
caa
had them come rescue you
listen i've just made the third one
there's 6 billion in profit i'm calling
my apple watch by the way i have not had
anything beyond a per diem from my apple
watch by the way by the way by the way i
got the rose gold one my wife loves it
by the way this was
oh this is my retirement gift by the way
what is
the apple watch the apple watch
yeah
i remember when it came out i was like
that thing is stupid that is just
redundant i don't need that
i just thought it was i i thought it was
uh it was kind of like uh
i was with someone who kept looking at
their watch and i was like why did why
did she even have to watch and i
realized she had an apple watch and she
was getting text messages on it
so it's like instead of you know pulling
out your phone she's lit she was just
checking the watch because it kept going
off and she was like tapping on it and
then what you text with one finger
i have no idea i don't you know i don't
even wear a watch what does def leppard
mean like what is the death part what
deaf is like it's dope right like a dope
leopard it's like a leopard that's into
hip-hop not how they meant it at all
how did they mean it
i don't know you'd have to ask them but
i've been listening to them you know
knew the whole backstory of peter
jackson and his like you know
advertisements for the airline and all
the drama but you don't know about def
leppard i feel like you would know that
more than anything like that would be
the one thing that you knew because
there's so much you don't know but i
feel like you wouldn't know that
that's just so in your wheelhouse to
know how what am i [ __ ] eddie trunk i
don't know who that i don't know i don't
know who eddie trunk is eddie trunk is
is all of that historian he's like
i want people to pay attention to this
there's nothing wrong with dating
somebody 10 years older or 10 years
younger but understand you will have
moments like this well one person will
be like i have no idea what you're
referring to who is eddie trunk
eddie trunk
exists outside your wheelhouse
okay i mean who was i listening to the
other day you freaked out
oh my god bill was playing jodeci like
it was [ __ ] 19 i don't know 94 or
something like that any but like i was
obviously so excited but i was like are
we at a dance
at my yeah now if i if i can
if i know who jodeci is how do you not
know who eddie trunk is i feel like i'm
doing more work here
really
no i'm kidding okay i'm like i'm pretty
sure eddie odyssey was more popular than
whoever eddie trunk is
i don't even know who that is but i'm
willing to bet that jodeci was more
famous than him
am i right hey maybe we need to do a
versus
petty truck eddie trunk versus chodesy
the versus nobody wanted to see
[Laughter]
both sides just going i don't know who
that is
um but if they had the apple watch maybe
that's what we need to bring this
country together a random verses
of two totally different genres
i want to pitch myself for an apple
watch 9-1-1 call to my agent
i want to do it right now yeah
and i'm gonna do like that jesse smullet
dude i'm gonna i'm gonna create
something
that happens to me sorry still a bad
topic
that is a sore one
do you see joey vehicle with joey via
gomez said is he's the first guy that
ever went to jail for kicking his own
ass
you know nia come on we all have a hero
fantasy
the man followed through with it you got
listen you got to give it up to him he
actually [ __ ] had a plan and he
carried it out
not every movie works nia you could say
that's the thing about it that's the
thing about it it could have been a
short film
he could have made
a really like deep
like well-acted really interesting kind
of film about that subject like it could
have been a creative exercise well you
know reality tv is a lot bigger than
movies these days nia so he went real
yeah you know i'm gonna stop talking
about it because it's just you know
nia how did the trusty smullet
incident affect you
no when it first happened of course you
know this is what they're gonna do to
you neil did a little you know thing on
my stories about it because i felt so
awful but yeah it's it's it's
complicated it's just like you when you
have your hit tv show
and okay we're bringing nia and she just
said
you know just once again just we are
agreeing to not bring up the jesse
smullet case that's it absolutely that's
the the
writer
nia thank you so much for joining us you
look absolutely radiant oh thank you and
congratulations
on your your uh your your big new tv
show it's an essay hit i saw apple
watches was advertising on it you gotta
get an apple watch yeah now let me ask
you this just going back
you know
do you plan on faking a hate crime at
all like a justice mallet
you know what i'm
i'm sorry i have the renee hills storms
out of interview yeah i specifically
asked to not be asked about this and you
had the audacity you had the audacity to
ask me about it
yeah i don't know man
are you getting any questions still are
you still giving people advice i haven't
been on the podcast in so long i have no
idea i know it sucks not anymore
so what's happening are people sending
in questions
you know what's funny the same questions
you ask about the podcast you could even
be asking about me we don't even know
each other anymore we've had we've had
two kids
we pass each other in the hall two we're
just two ships in the night two ships in
the night you know so we're out here
in a red roof inn trying to reconnect
i busted my leg i was reaching for the
bible
i had my apple watch on i should have
just played john 13.
can you watch things on your apple watch
like you can watch on your iphone like
you watch youtube and stuff on your
apple watch i don't know i feel like
this is a better commercial for the
apple watch because we've said apple
watch a million times and there's
probably
i imagine some clever person on the
internet is going to be like hey change
letting uh he just dedicated her podcast
to [ __ ] apple watch i feel like they
should send us some and we can test them
out and then we can give our honest
reviews i don't want to [ __ ] watch i
do apple i do i would love uh the the
band yo
technology
what is this part called on a watch
what's this the band the band yeah i
want a band to be can they make a metal
band or is it only like plastic
well nia if you have a metal band that's
going to drag you under the water when
you drive your car into the lake
because you're texting between your
iphone and your eye watch maybe it's
leather maybe a nice soft does a cow
really have to die
so you can [ __ ] break your leg in a
barn maybe it's a biodegradable plastic
anyway maybe that's what happened to the
farmer he was killing the cow
minty icy blue is a color that i'm
really into right now so you can send it
in that color way i love how you're
talking about it this long like you
think they're actually gonna do it
listen all they can say is no
all they can say is no
i like that i'm gonna be oprah right now
i like that
and that's how we started then nia wrote
a book called all they can say is no nia
how many times girl did you hear no
wow
did you
did you hear no growing up and when did
you decide
was it after or before you got your eye
watch you as the antagonistic talk show
host i feel like is a character you
really should explore
it's not a character yeah right that's
what i'm doing
hey uh
podcast host antagonistic podcast host
and sad news i heard some poor kid uh
died playing hockey yeah high school
yeah very sad
somebody skate hit him in the neck now
that happened to clint malachuk way back
in the day
he was playing goalie and uh you know
people
crashed the net
and then goaltenders ended up getting
some sort of i believe
to change the equipment so i think this
will definitely
um
change the equipment that happened to a
friend of mine
in my high school
same thing skate went right he had the
scar and everything but it just didn't
quite didn't quite go deep enough for
the jugger yeah it happens it seems like
it happens once every [ __ ] five
million games
i mean the amount of hockey i've watched
my whole life i've only seen it happen
once and it was clark chuck it's a freak
freak freak thing so it's a freak
accident thing yeah well well that
brought the whole thing down
because i don't know
are you running out of things to talk
about
no i talked about mike nezmuth dying
which really bothered me
you know three of the four monkeys are
dead
mickey dollars goes that means i'm next
that's the logic that's the logic
first it's the people you watch what's
if betty white just died the last person
on the marry tyler moore show so
literally a show that was putting out
new episodes that i was watching when
new episodes the whole [ __ ] cast is
dead
of natural causes
are you having like some sort of like
weird like i'm a moral person like not
more immortal and i'm gonna die type of
thing
like what's going on right now
yeah oh okay it cut it you wait you wait
you get i'm gonna be in my mid-50s nia
and it's just like i remember 15 years
ago it kind of seems like a while ago
another example like your partner is
going to start having like a midlife
crisis and you're going to be like whoa
man
are you okay over there
first of all you don't have nesmith
the skate it's just like sheesh
first of all you don't have a midlife
crisis at 53. 53 times
what's 53 times 2 well i mean yes no
it's not the middle of your life but no
it's not even close you think i'll make
106. well the thing is i always feel
like let's just say we live to 100. so
that's for me i'd be like yes 50 is
mid-eight like
all right well i'm going to be 54 in
june so i'm on the other side
i'm on like the 13th hole neal downhill
from here
well i'll be there holding your hands
oh you are going to be the worst one i'm
on my deathbed you're going to you're
going to just be like
oh my god he rang the buzzer again i
should never should have given him that
eye watch
apple apple watch whatever
no by that time it really will be a chip
and you know what all you have to do is
think about something that you want and
then
someone will come tend to you how about
that
i just i don't see that existing on my
level
uh this is what's going to happen when
you're old and feeble i'm not going to
put you away i'm going to put you in a
wing of the house that i never go to i'm
just kidding no but i'll
give you a nurse
and i'll set you up with a comfortable
bed of course you're gonna outsource
taking care of me when i'm old that is
so that is so you you're gonna get me a
[ __ ] old guy nanny
well what you keep [ __ ]
you
go down rodeo drive looking for some old
guy wearing ed hardy that you're gonna
hook up with
wow and i'm just gonna have them play
movies for you all day like all your
favorite movies and everything like that
like so you'll just be sort of laughing
and
i don't know wait can we do this now i
would sign up for that the final year of
my life let's do it yeah just just just
play all your favorite movies and things
and
take you out for a little walk no of
course i'd be there what are you talking
about i'm gonna be feeding you soup and
no
rubbing your feet no that other stuff
okay now we're now we're past the first
four days of that
oh my god i'm so exhausted of taking
care of my old husband
let's go to
oldhusband.net and see what my options
are for a less old husband
oh i was just i was just saying for like
taking care of me you know what i mean
try to get the uh
the new dumper bed he can shed in the
bed and he can dump him in the tub
afterwards
it's a tub it's a [ __ ]
they have like ceiling to floor windows
when you die
the bed just slides towards the window
and goes right off the side of the house
what a great idea
apple didn't come up with that
yet
the apple bed we just just gave them the
idea of the apple bed
there'll be some women make a 911 call
on her apple watch that her old husband
that she married for money was banging
her missionary style and just collapsed
on her and she can't get him off i'm
laying underneath my rich husband
i think he's dead his chest hair's in my
mouth this is bothering me i'm calling
i'm calling you
from my eye watch
not iwatch apple watch why is it the
iphone i don't know
what does the i stand for wait a minute
isn't i as in me
like myself or
probably
internet maybe internet fall
how about we'll just go with ignorant
with the two of us
i'm sure it's so obvious too
what is what it what what it stands for
hey i asked to somebody a sound person
one time
on a movie i asked them what adr stood
for and they didn't know they go audio
she's like oh my god wait a minute i
know what the [ __ ] that means adr adr no
department
repair no
for those of you not in the business of
show
um
adr
is after you do after you do a movie
there'll be lines a tv show
oh jesus christ or an animated show
anything where your voice is recorded
thank you for making that point so clear
any other forms of media that you would
like to talk about
super eight movies
actual film
digital
all mediums in the universe has yet to
be created but anyway you have to come
back you have to come back sometimes and
re-record your lines for for
various reasons like that audio might
have not picked up a certain word or you
didn't say something clear enough or
whatever the case so that's what adr is
you come back and you go in the studio
and they queue it up on a big screen
they queue up where you say your lines
and
you do them over again
so bill's googling
alternative no no no no no that's not it
no that's
there we go automated dialogue
replacement yeah so
it's basically if you're in a scene and
you're running down a hall and your
shoes are slapping on the floor they
can't hear the line that you said
so then
they play it back to you and you're in
the booth and they just have the scene
going the murderer is down the hall no
he's right there and then when you
yelled oh [ __ ] you already started
running so then they beep you and they
go beep
beep beep and you have to go oh [ __ ]
that was good
try it again you're a little little
little late little sooner oh [ __ ] no too
quick too quick
for a perfect example and you just keep
my pinned tweet which was the birthday
thread for bill and the first video on
there is him doing adr at the simpsons
so you can no i'm not
is that not you doing adr no that's me
recording i was actually doing the lines
the lines oh yeah
yeah and then afterwards if they had
if for some reason i made like a noise
it would and it usually doesn't happen
in animation
yeah but i i did it for ref no
no you know what they come up with a new
line
this is what this is the adr in
animations they come up with a new line
but the mouth still moves the same you
know what i mean so then you got to fit
it in
to the mouth
to the mouth yeah they might change a
word or whatever
so what you were doing on the simpsons
was not adr but did you have to do adr
for the simpsons at one point or no no
okay
all right so it doesn't exist in
i think i i don't know
well because you would never be making
an unless you made a noise within the
room you were recording it yeah
yeah okay
automated
dialogue
replacement
we've learned something i bet yeah i
picked the the apple watch i said it
right the apple watch has it
you know all right well i what's his
face the great andrew themeless from
beverly hills has not barely killed his
own beverly hills andrew themless has
not sent me the reads yet
if i were doing a remake of less than
zero i would cast andrew thumless in it
in some way shape or form maybe in the
andrew mccarthy role like don't you see
him playing that
i actually i do
yeah andrew playing andrew he's laughing
at this right now like don't you think
thumbless i feel like you would be great
in something like that you have you have
the look for it you've got the look all
right i gotta pause now because i don't
have any advertising or any of your
questions oh my god we already did 43
minutes of babbling babbling on here i'd
like to think i brought something
special to the podcast this episode
oh jesus nia i don't know how i do this
every week without you you were amazing
you did it was fun to uh bounce some
ideas off you thank you thank you it was
great to be here now i'm gonna go
disappear for another five years
no you're not no i'll be back all right
we just have to get on the get on the
sketch you haven't been on the podcast
so long i don't know where my other
microphone is there you go
i'll tell you that's a long time all
right um
when we come back
we'll have advertising and questions all
right
all right i'm back i'm back i got the
reads and everything and what a
difference
a couple hours makes um
as all of you already know i just
literally just found out about the
untimely and shocking passing of uh
bob saget and uh
i don't even know what to say i'm just
absolutely in shock um
[Music]
i mean i don't know what else to say
than what everybody else said just like
absolutely the nicest guy
and just so goddamn funny and um
absolutely loved
making people laugh and love jokes and
whenever i would text with him
he would go on until you stopped like i
don't care if it was like three in the
morning
if you were joking back and forth that
guy just
loved to improv and
just make people laugh and one of the
most amazing things that i found about
that guy was he was literally friends
with comedians
that were only a couple years into the
business
all the way
to legends
working in vegas
some of whom who weren't selling as many
tickets and kind of were working off the
strip he would fly out there he'd go to
their shows encourage them tell them
they're funny and have dinner with him
and um
i don't know i met him i believe the
first time i met him was probably on the
opium anthony show i can't remember if
it was the virus torah for he was in
studio first but i was immediately was
just struck with how down to earth he
was it was [ __ ] bob saget right who
you know
and um
[Music]
yeah i mean he was just wired to wire i
knew a little more than 15 years and
just wired a wire
was just an absolute sweetheart i'd
never had one argument with him
um
he was just the nicest guy and i really
very thankful that i had a very complete
friendship with them
you know we told each other that we
loved each other shared you know
you know stories about growing up and
how the hell we both ended up being
comedians and um
yeah man
i mean
if that guy wasn't making people laugh
he was out organizing a benefit to help
other people out and that
is why you see
the kinds of tributes that he's getting
um
it's just [ __ ] brutal [ __ ] brutal
absolutely in shock
so
with that
um
wow
well
jesus christ someday i'll i will tell
you guys
i'll tell you more stories that he would
he would get a [ __ ] kick out of
um but it's always tragedy plus time so
all right
let's leave it at that okay all right
all right back to the podcast rest in
peace bob
um i love you to death but you knew you
already knew that you already knew that
why did i just say i love you to death
he would have got a kick out of that
stupid all right butcher box everybody
um meal prepping is difficult
not as difficult as when a good friend
of yours dies all right this is going to
seep into the rest of the podcast sorry
butcherbox makes it easy butcherbox is a
subscription service that takes the
guesswork out of finding high quality
meat
butcherbox sources their meat from
partners with the highest standards for
quality no more searching the grocery
store for 100 grass-fed beef free-range
organic chicken
wild caught
seafood and more
their source their sourcing decisions
are made holistically
keeping the farmer the planet the animal
in your family and mind
[Music]
i wonder how the animal feels about that
every month butcher box ships a curated
selection of high quality meat right to
your home free shipping for the
continental united states no antibiotics
or ratted hormones each box contains
between 8 to 14 pounds of meat ladies
depending on the box you choose that's
enough for 24 individual meals
uh unless you're one of those skinny
guys eats all the hot dogs you could
probably do in one meal
packed fresh and shipped frozen for
convenience so you can save time on your
next grocery store trip customize your
own box or go with one of theirs either
way you get exactly what you want for a
limited time butcher box is offering new
members a great deal for the new year
sign up at
butcherbox.com you'll receive the
ultimate
uh new year's bundle in your first box
this deal includes ground beef chicken
thighs and pork butt
uh that's more than seven pounds of meat
added to your first box for free get
this new year's bundle before it's gone
by going to butcherbox.com
all right true bill
do you know why
free trials renew without your consent
it's a business scam out to get you
well yeah
that's pretty self-explanatory don't let
greedy corporations pocket your money
download true bill to take control of
your subscriptions here we go trubill is
the new app that helps you identify and
stop paying for subscriptions you don't
want need one or simply forget about it
on average people save up to 720 a year
with true bill you got to have this
because nobody looks at their credit
card statement they just look at the
friggin
how much you owe uh because companies
make subscriptions hard to cancel true
bills makes it incredibly simple just
link your accounts and true bill will
cancel your unwanted subscriptions in
one tap that's great you got a heavy in
the room
and your true bill concierge
is there when you need them to cancel
unwanted subscriptions so you don't have
to don't fall for subscription scams
start canceling today at
truebuild.com i gotta get this go right
now
truebill.com it could save you thousands
of dollars a year truebuild.com
remember that podcast where nia's going
why do you have three different cell
phone numbers and it went all the way
back to the early 2000s when i had an
internet phone number
i paid for that
like for i i swear to god like 12 years
and i think i only used it once it
didn't work
um
it was probably something bobby told me
about dude you get your own in and yet
number dude
you do a gig dude bam whip you're on the
internet
uh stamps.com if you're a small business
owner you're busy enough that it is as
it is you don't have time to deal with
the hassle man of going to the post
office with stamps.com you can skip the
trip and never waste another dollar or a
minute stamps.coms lets you print
official postage
right from your computers so you can
spend less time at the post office more
time running your business you've heard
me talk about stamps.com they've been
sponsoring our shows for over nine years
now and if you haven't tried it what are
you waiting for whether you're in office
sending invoices a side hustle
etsy shop
or a full-blown warehouse shipping uh
out orders stamps.com will make your
life easier all you need is a computer
and a standard printer no special
supplies or equipment you're up and
running in minutes printing official
postage for any letter any package
anywhere you want to send
save time and money this year with
stamps.com sign up with the promo code
burr for a special offer that includes a
four-week trial free postage and a
digital scale no long-term commitments
or contracts just go to stamps.com click
the microphone at the top of the home
page and enter the code bur
um all right here's a sagitt story for
you i got to change the names here
um one of the last times i hung out with
him
um i was hanging you know with a bunch
of comics some musicians and everything
typical comedy store just a great mix of
people we were up on the roof
thanks to mike binder and his um
documentary they built a little area up
there where you can
smoke cigars he did it for that
documentary he did about um the comedy
store so we're up on the roof
and we would tell you know just talking
comedy
and uh
there's this story about this one comic
i can't say the guy's name
but his deal
is so bad his deal
was when a comic would die
he would call up that comics agent and
be like oh my god i heard about
so-and-so i'm so sorry i just want to
make sure you're doing okay and then
they'd be like oh gee so-and-so i'm so
glad you called it's so nice for you to
reach out
um and then in the comic book yeah if
there's anything i could do you know you
know i'm always here for you buddy we
all love so-and-so but
and then in the end he goes yeah listen
and if he had any corporate dates on the
book you need me to cover just let me
know he was actually calling up
to take the dead comics gigs
under the guise of acting like he gave a
[ __ ] so anyway
um
how do i tell the story without giving
away who it is they [ __ ]
there was a story uh a comedian
his wife was downstairs making breakfast
the guy died in the morning okay that's
the loose version of what happened
so we were all just sitting there
thinking about that
and then i don't know where saggit goes
so and so probably came by and asked for
his eggs
[Music]
i can't do it justice i also had to
leave out so many details but it was the
[ __ ]
line of the night and i remember i was
up on the roof with bartnik and bartnik
has this thing when somebody just does a
really dark sick joke which was so much
of bob's humor
which is so funny because he was such a
loving caring guy he could just go so
dark i remember bardic just closing his
eyes and just
threw his head back and started laughing
and
um i remember laughing
and and yelling out line of the night
and i remember seeing how happy
yeah how happy that made him
you know there is something to be said
about dying young because then you don't
have to hang around and watch all your
friends die
you know i always wondered what it was
like you know these people lately like
betty white
dying at like [ __ ] 99 it's just like
you literally everybody you went to
school with is dead everybody you got
like movies you did like everybody's
dead
that's got to be like why isn't anybody
asked
i guess it's not a nice thing
to ask an older person but i would love
you know like
one of my relatives lived close to 105
and she was on like her third set of
friends
she was a card player you know she
always played bridge and everything they
always say that's so good for your brain
and she just was sharp as attack right
to the very end
and um
i remember
my relatives telling me yeah she's
outlived
the people she grew up with the next
generation the generation after that
yeah she'd always be playing cards
with women in their 60s and 70s
and you know i'd come back you know and
every 10 years there'd be a different
group of women and
she would still be sitting there it's
just [ __ ]
it's like one of those actors that just
never leaves law and order
the whole cast changes around him
all right let's do some of the uh
let's do some of the uh questions here
for the week all right useless christmas
present
uh dear billy [ __ ]
i have a useless christmas present
my mom wanted to give me your action
figure from the mandalorian for
christmas so she went ahead and ordered
one and a package came in the mail a few
weeks later the only problem was the
package was giant confused she opened up
the package to find a giant
big headed
mayfield cardboard cutout oh no
turns out the action figures don't come
out until next year so they sent this
instead
so now i have this life-sized cardboard
cut out of you in your mandalorian
outfit
and i have nowhere to put it i laughed
my ass off for 10 minutes straight
and thought you'd enjoy the story i'm
definitely keeping this useless piece of
[ __ ]
i've attached a picture for your
enjoyment thanks for bringing
enjoyment to my life
oh my god it's [ __ ] huge
what the hell would you do with that
um i don't know why don't you reboot
weekended bernie's
[ __ ] drive around with that thing i
have no idea
uh but thank you for watching the show
and thank you for caring enough to to
order uh the action figure
all right sr 71 blackbird pilot
tells story
the story you were trying to recollect
this past monday regret oh regarding
the ground speed checks
oh okay let's see if this is audio
or is it uh
okay so yeah
okay center aspen 20. you got a ground
speed radar for us there was a pause
longer than normal aspen and i show
uh
1942 knots no further inquiries were
heard after the on that freaks okay
all right can i read all of this
okay so basically what happened is i
guess there was some guys flying around
and somebody goes to do an altitude
check which i guess is like a big dick
thing in aviation that if you're flying
the highest you know you got the biggest
balls typical dumb guy [ __ ] right
so anyways here's the story of somebody
who did that and then got
got basically topped like three or four
times within the transmission here
uh throughout its nearly 24-year career
the lockheed sr71 blackbird mach3
strategic was
reconnaissance aircraft remain the
world's fastest and highest flying
operational aircraft from eighty
thousand feet it could survey a hundred
thousand square miles of the earth's
surface per hour
so it comes as no surprise
if thanks to astonishing flight
characteristics the aircraft set
numerous speed and altitude records
throughout his career nevertheless the
blackbird wasn't an easy plane to fly as
sr-71 pilot brian schull recalls in his
book sled driver there were a lot of
things we couldn't do in an sr 71 but we
were the fastest guys on the block and
love reminding our fellow aviators of
this fact people often asked us
if because of this fact it was fun to
fly the jet uh fun would not be the
first word i would use to describe
flying this plane intense maybe even
cerebral jesus christ
so that thing was squirrely going faster
than anything else at 80 000 [ __ ]
feet dude those guys are nuts
i like my little egg beater hair uh
helicopter however according to show
there was one day in our sled experience
when we would have to say there was pure
fun to be the fastest guys out there at
least for the moment i'll always
remember a certain radio exchange that
occurred one day
as walt my back seat
my backseater and i were screaming
across southern california 13 miles high
13 miles high
we were monitoring various radio
transmissions from our other aircraft as
we entered los angeles airspace though
they didn't really control us they did
monitor our movement across the scope
um
i heard uh cessna asked for a readout of
its ground speed 90 knots center replied
moments later a twin beach required the
same 120 knots center answered we
weren't the only ones proud of our
ground speed that day is almost
instantly an f18 smugly transmitted
uh center dusty 52 request ground speed
readout there was a slight pause then
the response
620 knots on the ground dusty all right
so he just big league those the guy in
the cessna and then the twin another
silent pause as i was thinking to myself
how ripest situation this was i heard a
familiar click of a radio transmission
coming from my back cedar
uh it was at that precise moment i
realized walt and i had become a real
crew for both of us were thinking in
unison how cool is that senator aspen
20. you got a ground speed readout for
us there was a longer than normal pause
aspen i show
1940 nuts
no further
inquiries were heard on that frequency
that's [ __ ] awesome
um
oh
men that's how we break balls all right
dictator idea
oh i had a good one the other day i
can't remember it
oh it's just a simple one god damn it
i'll have to start writing them down hey
william the dictator long time listener
first time writer yes we've been asking
i've been asking my listeners me and the
voices in my head i've been asking the
listeners
um
you know if you were a dictator what
would be something that you would
implement okay so hypothetically i've
just become leader this is this this guy
here uh of
guess let's go with america and i've
i've got total control all right you're
the dictator of america wonderful first
things first free health care and
education for everyone not because i
give a [ __ ] but i have no use for broken
dead stupid people
all housing food needs are provided for
you all this should foster good will
between me and the people then i remove
the economy money will no longer be
necessary
all right
well how do you keep the military and
all these other guys at bay who want
their money a person is 100 taken care
of in terms of schooling clothes
amenities etc as long as they hold down
a job
it doesn't matter what it is you do a
job you got to keep existing
all right well then how do you keep
people from [ __ ] uh taking easy jobs
you know what i mean like hey i'll push
a broom i'm not going to become a brain
surgeon why do i want to dedicate all of
that if so i could just push a broom and
be taken care of
don't mean to poke holes let me read the
rest of this i make sure i have enough
people work infrastructure jobs to keep
things running smoothly entertainment
will still be a big industry and people
will still have weekends to blow off
steam after all i want a happy
population because people work harder
and if they don't well
i always like carlin's bit about
bringing back crucifixion
oh jesus you crucify him crime will only
have two punishments capital punishment
or life
in the slave pence
weed will be legal i turn the focus of
this country from corporate consumerism
to scientific research every available
extra resource will be devoted towards
the development of every scientific area
with the ultimate goals being eternal
life
for me
uh infinite energy as or as close as one
can get complete command over our dna
able to make superhuman gene warriors
highly intelligent human computers etc
faster than light travel and contact
with whatever the [ __ ] we find
there in the void of space
there are these are just sort of the big
points i'd hit after becoming the
dictator of america thanks for all the
laughs
chuckles and go [ __ ] yourself wow man
you got a plan here
man i think you would have to be a world
dictator to make that work if you're
gonna eliminate money and all of that i
don't know how you're gonna do that
and uh
still coexist with the rest of the world
because we owe them money it's just like
well we got rid of money man we don't
know we don't have any anymore uh
world's best dictator
uh hey there's sag and red baggins
uh my first action as a dictator would
be make the world a better place
and goes as follows i would create a
health status based tax and payroll
system your base income tax percent will
reflect your body fat percentage wait
that's over my head i would create a
health status based
tax and payroll system your base income
tax percent will reflect your body fat
percentage
all right for safety and to maintain
revenue the best score would be 10
maintaining 10 percent for many years
will result in a better retirement
package i imagine the revenue would
shrink up but so will the medical tax
burden of this fat ass nation the amount
of pay you earn would be based on an
algorithm
governed by a semi-annual blood test and
a physical fitness test halt all plastic
surgeries unless life surge uh
threatening for 10 years then tell
everyone i'm revamping the plastic
surgery in industry for improvements for
everyone would have to re prepay their
requests for the 10 years after the 10
years are up and the money is collected
i would tell all the vanity-based
surgery requests to [ __ ] off
oh you double cross them
how are you going to stay
stay on your your [ __ ] king's chair
with all those guys coming at you with
their scalpels
uh then i would tell all the money
take all the money and give free
surgeries to people suffering from
deformities at birth or innocent
accident
accidental deformities
um any serious criminals found guilty
via hard evidence such as rapist killers
filthy banker [ __ ] or corrupt
government officials would be sent to a
top secret prison but they would be
what the masses but they wouldn't that
would be what the masses think what
would really happen is they get taken to
the great pacific garbage patch with
they get injected with the ebola and
aids and left stranded to die of sunburn
and dehydration jesus i'd also make you
fly us around to various cigar
plantations
thank you for what you do
and thank you to all the uh comedians
i know nia is busy being a mother but we
do miss her on the podcast well look at
that you got her in the early part of
this take care oh great freckled [ __ ]
um
that's an interesting one you're going
hard there yeah i was gonna say if
you're gonna go after bankers and all
them you're gonna make sure you kill
them because they will [ __ ] regroup
and uh
yeah they'll do something
they'll come back at you all right
shower problem dear
little drummer [ __ ]
dear little drummer [ __ ]
pump
i'm 30 years old and have been in a
great relationship for about a year but
my girlfriend is always asking me to
shower with her we're not 15 anymore and
we've been dating a while so this isn't
about sex she says it's a great way to
be president and connect since there are
no phones or distraction which i agree
with because we have some of our best
conversations in there all this sounds
great except i'm [ __ ] miserable
during it we just have a normal shower
one shower head so when she's soaking up
the hot water for most of the shower i'm
sitting there freezing my ass off with
soap in my eyes
uh when i do get my 10 seconds of water
i feel like i'm walking a tightrope
squeezing by her in the small ass tub
uh should i be
a man and suck it up or bring it up and
ask for more time in the water by the
way your painter rants from last summer
still crack me up every time i think
about it love the podcast and wish you
and your family the best for 2022
i got it here okay because that's a
great thing your wife uh your girlfriend
wants to connect with you and everything
and uh you know happy wife happy life
same thing with a girlfriend so what you
should do
is you should up the level
of gayness to it or femininity whatever
you want to call it and just take a bath
with her
all right then you're both in the hot
water she can have a nice conversation
it actually takes a little bit longer so
she feels like you care more
and then you don't freeze your ass off
and you can just sit there doing you
know
active listening
oh that's amazing
oh i i love her she's great you know you
just do that
and then you're good all right anyways
that's the uh
that is the end of the podcast everybody
and uh
yeah man this was a weird one um once
again i can't believe bob is gone and uh
you know if you guys didn't know him go
read all the tributes and uh the world
would be a better place if everybody
tried to be more like
the great bob saget was um
that is it i will talk to you guys
on thursday okay
you